- We recognize that
students walk in the door
of this classroom with
issues of status behind them.
That they recognize
themselves as being a science
person or a non-science person
and that it's through student discourse
and group work that they
will start to dispel those
beliefs about not only
themselves but about their peers.
As we think about our equity
goal around science education,
that is central to it.
- We do go through a
process of teaching kids
what it is to actually work in group.
We get the kids to
understand some of the basic
behavior norms about group
roles and group work in general.
We start with a unit that's
all about group work.
- Students get that experience
for sure at the beginning
but we really recommend that teachers
come back to it when issues arise.
So there are times where they can just,
maybe just completely stop the lesson
and then it might go back to
some of the skill builders
and say let's do this one again.
We also really advise teachers
and I see them doing it
all the time, just reminding the students
what is their role?
What does it mean to play that role?
- As a group remember reporters, recorders
not only are you recording the information
and making sure that you
should have this specific
information that your group talked about,
but I'm gonna call on
you guys to give me your
answers 'cause I'm gonna
put them up on the board.
Each group member has a role.
They have to actually participate
in order for the group
to achieve whatever it is
they're trying to achieve.
- My job is the recorder-reporter.
So with that job I have to
write down all our notes
and all our step-by-step stuff.
- My job is the harmonizer.
If they're like arguing over a project,
I'll say well you don't need to argue.
It's just that we have to figure out who
can do which one or we can change roles.
- I am facilitator and I'm supposed
to keep everybody on task.
- I'm a materials manager.
So basically what I do,
if we're making a poster
I get the poster paper and the materials.
- They understand that they
all have a role to play.
And that I think is the biggest part of it
and that they take
agency over their group.
- [Holthuis] It is
absolutely critical for us
to help address issues of
equity in the classroom.
If I don't speak English
well I might have some other
tremendous skill that
is gonna come into play.
The curriculum provides students who might
traditionally not have
succeeded well in school
a lot of ins into the content.
- [Ryan] Each of those
students is bringing
an aspect of smarts into
the problem that they're
trying to solve around science.
- When a group is working well together,
it sort of just hums with the
discussion, the interactions.
(students talking)
- The whole year or like one day?
- [Holthuis] And see students
building off each other.
Not just talking at each other.
But there's something happening where the,
some of the whole is much
bigger than the parts.
- And it's only through making sure that
that group work is productive,
is useful, is respectful
and is targeted at learning
not only for themselves
but as a community that we will get there.
- [Allen-Sanchez] One of the
things that I like to say
as a part of one of our norms,
if one person is not done, no one's done.